all the dating coaches say to go to  Poland that's like because I'm gonna go  to the number one recommended to buy a  prize  it's not it's not to buy a bride it's  just like they have more feminine  traditional women that tend to be in  shape and pretty apparently I've never  been to Poland yeah I mean I I grew up  going to school and you know women would  be walking to school in high heels  makeup ready yeah like I've been to  Germany  um which it's not Poland but but it's  like compared to America and even here  the girls are like 10 times prettier  like I was in I went to a wedding I was  like oh my God like they would blow  everyone here out of the world